the GMB Union has announced that more
than ten thousand ambulance workers will
go on strike for two days later this
month they'll walk out on December the
21st and the 28th or joining me now is
our correspondent Saba Chaudhary who's
at the GMB headquarters in central
London uh many many organizations
striking at the moment Saba but this
will cause real worry for those who may
be depending on ambulances to get to
appointments at hospital or indeed those
who may have emergencies on that day
good afternoon it really is looking like
a Christmas period full of strike action
just last night it was the rmt union
which represents train workers saying
that they will be striking over the
Christmas period and today this Union
over here the GMB which represents some
ambulance workers are saying that they
will be walking out on the 21st and the
28th of December later this month now it
was just last week that the GMB Union at
10 000 of their members voted in favor
of walking out impacting nine of their
trusts across England and Wales and
they're saying that it essentially boils
down to money they're not happy with the
four percent pay increase that the
government have offered their workers
they're saying that it's tantamount to a
pay cut given inflation and the cost of
living crisis and that it's simply
unsatisfactory the members of the GMB
Union have also said though it's not
simply about money it's massive
contributing factor but it's also other
things specifically the shortage of
staff that they're seeing at the moment
and also the number of the the patient's
safety issue is something that is is
also a a secondary issue coming from
staff shortages now around a third of
the members have said that it's for
different factors including delays and
cuts that they believe uh that is the
contributing factor for why some of
their patients have died a third of
members said that now we're looking at
widespread delays as I say throughout
the Christmas period but their message
here is loud and clear they are on their
knees they say and unless the government
give in to their demands and hear them
out it's going to look like a very
difficult Christmas indeed